how large graphs respond to putting
competing constraints on them and the
new results will be
based on this preprint joint work with
Joe Neiman and Lorenzo sedu
um
so I'm talking about dense graphs and
putting competing constraints on them
and I want to emphasize I'm actually
interested in large finite graphs and I
want to know what happens to a finite
graph when I put two competing
constraints on it and informally I think
myself that
when you put competing constraints in
some sense it imposes a sort of tension
in that graph and I'm interested in how
the graph works out that tension just
informally
so to uh to make uh the the problem or
the project
uh to give it a better uh uh picture uh
I'm going to start with two
different combinatorial settings uh and
uh research over many years by of many
people on similar problems okay I'll
start off with uh densis packings of
unit spheres in D dimensional euclidean
space
and then I'll talk a bit about
permutation with extreme densities of
patterns One Two Three or as we heard or
sub permutations one two three three two
one as uh
then
describe them
so uh
when I talking here about dentist
packings
and I want to put it in this setting the
two competing constraints I'm thinking
of are I have a large number of units
fears in a big box
say the centers of the unispheres in a
big box unconstrained
and uh the constraint might be fixing a
covering fraction that is that the
Spheres centered at those points cover
40 of the volume something like that
fixed that's constraint and a different
constraint might be that the Spheres
cannot overlap so it's a separate
constraint the two together obviously
compete
for example two together you cannot have
uh uh covering fraction one
right but uh okay
um okay
let's see
in fact
if you
uh look at the problem as I stated the
densest packing if you look at the
optimum packing the the highest covering
fraction you can have in two Dimensions
uh
if you also at highest covering fraction
with the constraint of packing
in fact this is a unique configuration
that's how strongly they're competing
okay
four
uh
yeah
for permutations this is a picture of
the uh
admissible values of the two densities
the densities of decreasing triples
that's the uh increasing triples
and uh this is not our work this is old
work
um
and uh
there are many this portion of the
picture this portion illustrates very
clearly that they are competing that is
if I pick a density of one two three
increasing
down here then I can't have a very low
density of three to one it just okay
okay now
um I
describe these two packing problems uh
to these two combinatorial problems as
actually extremum extremely common torix
right these are the densest packing this
is the extreme densities which
corresponds here to
density
corresponding to this is around 0.91
okay that's the highest possible packing
fraction and here
um
well yeah so here the the uh the
extremal uh problem is to look simply at
the boundary
okay and for any given value of the
density one two three determine what the
uh largest possible value of three two
one is and not just what the densities
are but actually what are the
permutations that achieve that
that's a typical this is an old uh
extremal permutation problem
um I point out for later use this point
here that this curve is not actually
very smooth and uh I'll talk about that
in a minute
okay so as I've been illustrating here
uh
the story of competing putting competing
constraints on a combinatorial system uh
is has been studied for a long time in
the extremal case what I'm going to talk
about today and and in that extreme case
you can actually see the competition
it's very clear even in the extrema but
what I'm talking about today today is
going to be putting on those constraints
but looking at the constraints away from
the constraint away from the extremum
and seeing the competition and seeing
how the system
responds to those competing constraints
so in two Dimensions uh
the uh Optimum the picture I showed you
uh this is the optimum this is the
highest possible value of covering
fraction
it's
exactly this
but it's been known since the 1950s that
if you put a constraint if you look at
uh packings with
covering fraction or packing fraction
0.81
it will still look very much like that
picture
0.797 down to 0.71 you can take that
packing fraction or covering fraction
down
to about 0.71 and have the following be
true that a typical
packing
exponentially most packings will still
have
the orientational structure of this
this has a long-range orientation this
has an orientation you can see the
orientation of this you can see whether
you
it gets lost at 120 degree rotation but
between that it they're different
um that is maintained in uh with a
constraint down to about 0.71 when
there's a very sharp transition and it's
just lost
so again this is way away from way away
from the optimum this is occurring at
density or packing fraction 0.91 you can
go down to 0.71 and maintain this and
then it gets lost sharply that's the
kind of thing I want to talk about and
I'll be talking about that in graphs not
here but this is an analog
old history
um
so you say lost what happens
a typical configuration just does not
have long range Order anymore
and how to describe what's going on
there some sort of transition or
whatever I'll be talking about that but
more in terms of uh graphs than here you
can talk about it but I don't want to
get into that
and by the way I say uh there's a sharp
transition here very far from being
proven I mean people have tried to prove
this forever it's just very hard
so there's a lot of numerical evidence
uh you may want to accept that or not
that's personal
uh for permutations I told you about
that Kink here this actually does have
influence inside
okay
um
and that is proven in this paper
Well published a couple of years ago but
it's actually a bit older
um okay so now I want to talk about
graphs and the similar thing I want to
talk about sort of extremum problems and
then get away from the extremum and look
for the competition or the tension
between competing
constraints and I'll be talking about uh
dense graphs and uh constraints are just
going to be the edge and triangle
density it's an old problem as an
extreme problem this has been the first
first interesting result goes back to
about 1907 I think it is and tell
uh so it's got an old history and uh uh
the extremal theory is in pretty good
shape I would say
uh I'm going to start off my discussion
uh with a picture of the status of that
of the extreme theory in 2012
a paper by kirkov pakurko and raspberuff
this is a distorted picture the dark
outline is a distorted picture of the
accessible region of those two densities
The Edge density and the triangle dense
it's distorted for to be able to show
you some things it really should be very
thin okay
um
so a straight line nice smooth curve
this is all just a lot of
scallops down to this point okay
valid line for uh Tau equals Epsilon
Cube which is the relation between those
variables with uh for independent edges
just uh it'll be relevant for uh we're
going to talk about later
okay so this is the so this is all done
this is all done by 2012 they knew what
the accessible region is they knew what
the boundary was they knew what the
graphs are that achieved those
boundaries this is all done 2012.
foreign
I started a project with uh Lorenzo
sidoon in 2013 a year later
and uh
I want to point out just the the setting
might be useful where this came
historically
varadan published or put out the archive
preprint of their ldp in 2010.
and that was the ldp for GNP fantastic
result lots of consequences etc etc
among them he talked they talked a bit
about uh applying it to exponential
random graph models okay
the next year there was a paper by
Chatterjee diaconis
we print 2011 much more on exponential
random graphs and that stuff took off a
lot of people worked on followed up on
that
but the following year
was this paper
uh finished off the extremograph theory
and what our project was starting 2013
year after that was to mix these in
together okay to use the results of
strategy varadon basically that ldp to
fill in things in the uh
extremo graph Theory problem
okay
I may not say much about this right now
but if you have you may have questions
about it later about what exactly is the
uh connection between this project and
the ergoms
which already used the ldp they're quite
different
anyway again 2013 we started off as
follows uh pick a point inside in the
interior of that raspberry triangle an
accessible pair of Edge and triangle
Nancy's but in the interior
look at the Z sub n z sub n is just
accounting account counting the number
of graphs on end nodes with Edge density
Epsilon triangle density Tau but with a
little wiggle of Delta
okay
first thing we proved is that this
consecutive limits exist
take the limited n first you just I'm
trying to get the rate of growth of this
Z the typical thing to do okay
uh take the log divide by N squared take
the limit of that and then the limit is
Delta goes to zero we prove this limit
exists this would be naturally called
the boltzmann entropy it's just the
counting of a number of states or the
rate of growth of the county of the
number of states
also in that first paper we proved a
variational principle for that boltzmann
entropy the boltzman entropy for Epsilon
tau is just the maximum of The Shining
entropy of graph over graphons with
those constraints of the triangle The
Edge density of the
uh uh graph on is Epsilon edged triangle
density of the graph on is Tau
this is the Shannon entropy
uh and uh yeah at least it's just how
you compute the densities okay so yeah
and this is just a variational principle
and again it comes from uh that
Chatterjee uh varodon paper you just
modify the proof a bit you had to modify
you know nothing's all that serious
okay now I want to describe our new
results so
I think it'll be useful
and try this
to um
no this is wrong
yes yeah yeah
so let me reproduce
the uh
raspber of
triangle
with the uh irdish Reni curve
inside
remember this is Edge density
Edge density half this is triangle
density between zero and one
what we prove is that this curve
is an open set
which is bisected by the second half of
that erdog trendy curve
part of the the uh part of the curve
with Edge density bigger than half
there's an open set bisected by that
which and if you bisect that open set
you've produced
two open sets you partition the open set
into three pieces an open set an open
set and the curve partition that'll I'll
be talking about these two open sets a
lot okay
foreign
so what we prove is that
for any point in either of these two
open sets
is unique
Shannon entropy Optimum graph on unique
graphite
and
that graph on is bipodal I'll tell you
what that means in a minute but
basically what it means it is uniquely
defined by four real numbers
which are in fact analytic functions of
Epsilon and Tau
in these regions
and
of course uh this is a singularity so I
have
a analytic surface
two-dimensional analytic Surface Two
Dimensions is the Epsilon tab I have a
two-dimensional analytic surface in four
dimensions over this
two-dimensional analytic surface
in four dimensions over this with uh
with a common boundary of singularities
hey
this is basically I mean this we uh this
is the
uh main result of that preprint I
mentioned uh this is new results we had
started this project Lorenzo and I had
started this project
2013. it's roughly 10 years written
about 10 papers not alone with a lot of
help from uh co-authors there was quiren
there was Rick uh Kenyon and now Joe
Neiman Okay so in 10 years we wrote a
bunch of papers this is what we were
aiming at we wanted to see this kind of
singular Behavior
in this setting okay
um here's what I meant by saying it's
bipodal I I uh so this is the bipolar
graph on it's a graph on so this is zero
one course zero one which is uh
piecewise constant and these numbers
these letters represent the value of the
graph on in those regions and C tells
you the size of this okay that fully
describes that graph those four numbers
okay
Okay so
uh let me say a little more yeah okay so
um these numbers the eight the the four
numbers a b c d we actually have good
control over them we actually give
asymptotic expansions for those numbers
we can determine those numbers
as accurately as we want
okay and in the next couple of slides I
will
um give you though goes to asymptotic
expansions
so it makes use of this function of a
real variable
H so the first theorem discusses the
lower
open set
um
which was by far the harder case
the upper case I maybe I should say it
uh the upper case was basically solved
earlier in earlier work with Rick Canyon
quirred
uh but it did not show transition
because we didn't have what's going on
on the other side
okay and at that time we were not able
to deal with the lower set below Irish
Remy
and that is really the main result main
new element of this paper
anyway in that lower set here's the
asymptotic expansion for ABCD in terms
of
I'm using a slight this notation here to
understand what e and d and Delta is
it's defined here okay so e is just out
Epsilon but Delta is this it's deviation
from of Tau from uh the value on the
Curve
so that's the uh asymptotic expansions
below yurdish Randy above
uh it's
this uh I use different notation e and a
delta T this is not Delta times T this
is delta T and uh here's the expansion
which is a bit different from the
previous expansion
and this works above Ernest Randy the
other open set
uh this a naught is not defined here
it's defined here
now
um
a point I want to emphasize I said I I
actually emphasized at the beginning I'm
interested in how large finite graphs
respond to things okay and we respond to
competing constraints
um
this is slightly intuitive but let me
just say it I think you'll know what I
mean if a graph on Optima uh which is
opt uh which is optimizing our uh rate
function
is unique which is not talked about a
lot actually proving uniqueness is
extremely hard
okay but if it is unique
uh forgiven values of the constraints
Epsilon Tau inside rasborough
Triangle uh then uh as and the number of
nodes diverges and the window goes to
zero
you can prove exponentially I mean it's
part of the ldp formulation
exponentially most graphs with density
in that window
with uh Edge density in there triangle
density in there
will have a reduced zero one graph on
that is essentially it's the JSC Matrix
which is close to q and cut metric and
close to q and cut metric just means
exactly that for every finite subgraph
the densities are close that's exactly
what it means so this is a nice quick
way of saying that but that's equivalent
okay so this is saying that the results
that we're getting
on response to competing constraints
is concerns
what is happening to a large finite
graph the large finite graph with uh
yeah as I change the Epsilon and Delta
whether it's smooth or not whether
whether it's we're actually
proving not only the existence of this
unique graph on but in fact that it
varies not just differentiably but
analytically with Epsilon Delta which is
actually
more than you think we might need
differentiability would already show
that I have a transition but uh
analyticity is a lot more which I will
get to in a couple of minutes you had a
question yeah so could you give us some
intuition like I mean why is the
optimizer you know
why does it basically look like a four
parameter stochastic block model and
also for a given Epsilon what is the
optimizer trying to do I mean for an
Epsilon and Tau so I'll tell you
something about that historical setting
which again I'm uh
it might be useful okay so when we when
sudoon and I started this project 2013
the first thing we tried to do is well
we knew that that our Optimum graph on
is supposed to be uh uh the maximizer
for that function that's simplify well
you can compute that function
numerically that's a very simple
function you put in a uh some sort of uh
graph on function on zero one uh square
the square uh and you can compute it
well you can also optimize that
numerically that's not hard people have
been doing this sort of thing for a long
time so we did that we we we did was try
to find what the Optima looked like
okay and
there are two ways we thought of doing
that one start with a uh some sort of
multi-polynomial
in the two variables the other was by
taking piecewise constant things so we
tried that we tried taking
um piecewise constant functions where
you break up the set of vertices into uh
10 uh blocks Etc of different sizes of
course
optimize that well that's easy let's
find a dimensional problem you can you
can find out what are the parameters
that'll what are the size what is the
piecewise constant graph on which will
of a given size which will optimize this
well we did this actually starting with
16. so 16 by 16 boxes
and uh quiren who's uh working on the
project with us then was good at this
sort of thing and he optimized this
and we found you never needed more than
two by two you just didn't need those
others we think we were not expecting
this there's no reason to expect this
it's just what happened
and then well this but this is not a
proof okay but then we start exploring
once we did that for some value you know
we did that for certain values Epsilon
Tau and throughout here well then we
explored more and just took it imagine
it's true and start with 16 by 16 and
then plot out what does the optimizer
look like in various parts of the
accessible region and we ended up with a
rather complicated picture
uh
uh I don't
show you yeah why
we ended up with this picture uh this is
a picture okay this is there's no proof
in this okay this is just numerical uh
searches with the optimum
graph on look looks like and we found
that except on these curves
it was a unique that it was a unique
uh
graph on of a certain very simple kind
very simple kind
with uh which varied very smoothly
except when you got to these curves
where in fact there seemed to be a
singularity
and uh none of this have we been able to
prove except we just now proved it over
here
it's still 10 years what sorry the
optimizes in all the non-singular places
are our stochastic block models like
piecewise yes yes
and here we're proving it
and we would like to prove it here I
list that as the
second problem actually to prove what's
going on right here
yes
sorry just continuing on it so the
result you're presenting is about
counting how many graphs there are with
this Edge density attractive density
right not counting I mean uh kind of Z
is my counting right it's it's
symmetropy right so yes does this does
this result also now formally say
something about the ldp variational
problem for the addition any case uh
where the base is not supposed to be a
constant
repeat the question please so for the
large deviation for for the upper tail
large deviation for air does shred right
there is the so following strategy there
was work by lubetski Zhao where they
found this boundary for symmetry versus
non-symmetry right I'm sorry and
symmetry there means one symmetry is
just that whether or not it's added to
whether or not yeah
right so monitoring in this case now
given this result I could say something
about so this is yeah I I think this has
essentially nothing to do with with such
results those results are are
exponential random reference our
community and uh as far as I know
I don't know of anyone else except Frank
who has actually looked seriously at
taking the limits this way where
remember when you when you take the
limits we've done the cue the the
optimizing cue is a limit of
graphons or adjacency matrices of Highly
constrained graphs
you don't get that by the older examples
coming out of uh charity varadon they
used soft constraints which don't tell
you anything about the graphs themselves
okay
I I don't
so I'm sorry so this may not be
answering exactly your question okay but
let me just say what I what the work we
are presenting says the following that
in here for uh engine triangle densities
in those two open sets
we have
unique Optima which a unique Optimum of
the
shine an entropy with the constraint on
edge and triangle density
and smoothness with respect to variation
of that
and I don't know about the work that's
related to this almost at all okay
because because that that constraint is
very different constraining the uh
graphs to have very sharp values of Edge
and triangle density is uh it's a new
it's a new Wrinkle in that old
discussion the discussion that started
with Chatterjee varadan and then charity
dichonis
uh led to a lot of stuff we took a side
path after Kirko raspora came out and
did something a bit different
okay and I don't know of other papers
that discuss that
okay how am I doing time I'm expecting
I'm going to leave early 10 minutes I
have 10 minutes oh my goodness sorry 15
minutes ah even better
so let me go back
okay
any other questions before we go on yes
can you go back to your graph one
picture the ABCD
important
yes what how does c behave as a function
of the that's analytic what do you mean
they're all four parameters as I showed
you all four parameters are
analytic and it's not fair the fact that
it's analytic is not all that surprising
the thing is we prove first in order to
prove anything we prove that it's
the optimum has to be
of the shape has to be that's the first
thing
and once you do it finding this you just
put down a bunch of constraints the
thing has to have uh Edge density so and
so it has to have triangle density so
and so you get four
uh equations and you can invert and use
the inverse function theorem to get uh
smoothness okay it's it's being able to
bring it down to five Dimensions which
makes life wonderful
okay
okay
let me describe at least the first open
problem I think I'll have time for
um
uh I wanted and this is uh I'll have to
tell you what I mean by this symmetry as
an order parameter so here
in that first or second paper
um
we had done the following look at the
rats
look at this straight line here at Edge
density a half
going up to Triangle density 1 8. that's
straight line now for
parameter values on that line we
actually worked out what the
unique Optical we proved that there was
a unique optimal graph fund and we
determined what it was
and
um
it was the special case of this
where Edge density is one half and the
triangle density is anything between two
and eight so we prove that this very
symmetrical graph on I'll tell you why
it's symmetric symmetrical in that the C
is a hat
and a is equal to B
the fact that these three is automatic
so these are equal is another symmetry
so we we proved that on that line in the
raspberry triangle
the unique Optimum is a very symmetric
object
and
I'm sourcing out as an open problem
to prove that this is true a little bit
around that that is an open set
containing a an interval at least the
fact
fine in which this is the optimum
and here's why I want to do it and
here's why uh analyticity is significant
okay so let me just go off into uh
a little physics discussion really the
picture isn't all that uh necessary your
own uh experience will tell you the
following so if you look at a simple
picture of uh a real matter with uh uh
mass density and energy density
when the mass density is high which
means under high pressure the material
is solid crystalline solid solid at low
pressure it's fluid
in fact though the fluid if you decrease
the energy or temperature you can have
either a gas or liquid
and they can be in coexistence right
except if the temperature or energy
density is high enough beyond that and
you can't do that anymore this is a
critical point
and what it says is that the transition
that you're familiar with that when you
cool down a gas
you get liquid like on your windshield
when the inside of the car is cold
it condenses right
uh this transition
has a critical point which you can go
around by just varying the temperature
and pressure you vary the temperature
you can start from here and go to here
without going through a transition
you can't do that in your car because uh
the external pressure is going to be
atmospheric pressure it's very hard to
get around that really okay but but it's
been known since easily 1900 that that
doesn't seem to be a critical point for
the transition between fluid and solid
when you you you can't just raise the
pressure enough and go around it
if you're between the fluid State and
the solid state you have to go through a
transition
unknown for a long long time
there was some discussion of this
started in 58 by Lev Landau who said
well it's got something to do with the
fact that the solid
is symmetric the the crystalline
structure has a this High degree of
symmetry or low degree whatever you want
to call it compared to the fluid
okay
and what Landau said or what is
paraphrased by Phil Anderson here is
that the reason that there can't be a
critical point is that you can't he says
you can't lose symmetry smooth uh
continuously well he doesn't say the
word critics this is not mathematics he
says uh uh no way to grow it
imperceptively uh whatever anyway what
he is saying is that
uh
it's an intrinsic difference between the
two states solid the the symmetric State
and the non-symmetric state it's an
intrinsic difference and you can't
possibly go smoothly from one to the
other
there's a cute uh
short discussion of this in a paper by
in a book by depard that the argument uh
landau's argument
is essential just a little too
straightforward to be absolutely
convincing it's a nice phrase
not saying it's just wrong in fact I
believe it's wrong but it's actually a
tricky problem this has been an old
problem in physics for a long time why
why do you have why can't you have a
critical point going from fluid to a
song well what or another way to say it
if you know you have a fluid you know
you have a solid
why does it have to be a transition
where does it come from
where does it come from
okay so
um the reason
analyticity is important in our results
is that
imagine you could over here have an open
set
very symmetric open
graph
and over here we know what these are
already and they're not symmetric
well if you could prove it here you
could not possibly
go smoothly from here to here without
going through a transition it would be a
way of proving there's a transition
without getting anywhere near it notice
over here we prove a transition by
actually knowing what the graph on looks
like on either side and seeing it's not
differentiable for example
but if I want to do a long range
argument like this
uh you can do it with analyticity
because for example c c would be a half
everywhere in here and it's not a half
over here you can't go analytically from
a constant to a non-constant it's as
simple as that
but it gives you a very powerful
argument
of getting a transition long range you
know far away
so uh that is another reason why besides
pure Aesthetics I think why it is useful
to understand why in our new results why
our graphons are analytic in epsilon in
town
um
but is that five minutes and that's dead
plus discussion or with discussion
she should be with let's have a
discussion so let me stop now if there
is any discussion otherwise otherwise
I'll keep going so
all right well thank you very much then
I think there will be questions
and I already see one
I have some technical questions so on
the adult shiny curve a equals b equals
B in your bipolar graph right
I mean it's like the same concept for
the Irish
so then how do you define c looks like
secant no no I I actually Define c for
bipolar look at I actually assumed it
was bipolar and then then said what seas
for monopodal whatever you want to call
the Irish ready you don't need to say
okay then above the other training curve
and below the other training curve yeah
like
do you see a very sharp transition of
course yes but that you see was already
known sort of known in back 2013 where
we actually gave estimates on the
entropy itself
the uh
um
gave upper and lower bounds on the
entropy proving that along the uh uh
Irish Randy curve you had a uh a ridge
it could not be differentiable there
across it oh this was not
this we did not prove what it was like
on either side what we proved was it
couldn't possibly be differentiable
there
okay oh and that's a relatively minor
and also like when you consider the
small window around the edge triangle
density pair you always use the same
error Delta I think if you use different
error will you get the same results or
oh
uh
you just need to take the Delta going to
zero you could take them different and I
think we may have even done that change
them going to zero at differently they
need to go to zero yeah they you still
need to have them go to Zero by the way
you don't want them to go to zero well
I'm not gonna get it
it's the next question which is
somewhere a bit further away I had a
question right yes yeah that's what I
thought oh we were just trying to
understand what exactly happened uh
at these singularities at the upper
curve and lower curve I'm imagining that
for instance as you are trying to push
the triangle density up
then the diagonal elements of your
um bipodal thing yes are getting larger
and maybe do they have to go above one
at some point or and if you go down to
the off diagonal ones need to get better
like what what exactly what do you what
what do what do they hit at those curves
by the way so when we gave when I gave
you the uh
these asymptotic expansions you can see
exactly what the behavior is as the
Delta goes to zero as you get closer to
Traders you can see it's just written
right here this is below and the the
other one the next pit was above but
when you you said there is a line of of
uh singularities at this upper and lower
curves as well
no no there's only one curve it's the ER
curve where uh Tau equals Epsilon cubed
that's that's what this line is how is X
on here and the lower one is less than
less than independent edges number of
triangles above is more than there to
trendy of triangles and so this is what
we're proven this is the singularity but
I guess Chris's question is is about
what happens at these curves is there
any non-electricities there no no no
right this is just an existence of an
open set we didn't we don't say what the
open says they don't seem to have any
significance they don't have uh except
for technical reasons I guess thank you
yeah one final question here
if you would look at the part of the
erosion curve below Epsilon so Epsilon
less than one half are you able to say
that there's some open region there as
well would you expect that of course no
this is actually hard we weren't able to
do it we obviously tried weren't able to
do it and we think uh there is an
obstruction and we know what it is and
uh
so uh an analogous result
well we can say is not true so there is
it's not true that there is an open set
containing this or one open set or with
with those uh so but but you know you
could you it's not terribly surprising
the grand funds over here are very
similar to the graph funds over here
um uh whereas over here we're expecting
this all to be symmetric it's very
different what's going on below air
training to what's above it's very
different and we were not able to prove
anything on it but we can prove
that there is no analogous result
but it will still be a two block uh
graph we haven't proved it okay no no no
no it has not been proven no but it is
back hello yeah
in the interest of time
well there's a long launch break so you
can ask your questions during the lunch
break uh we will reconvene at two uh
enjoy your lunches
foreign